men are looking for sex women are
looking for resources time and attention
I like her she should have a channel I
like her it's a dance between the two
genders to get the other commodity from
the other without giving up there so for
example that's not even true though
really really let me explain hold on
before you do your explanation like this
is the easiest thing in the world okay I
can make so many personal taxes here and
I'm not doing it
he sounds like a little kid that was
bullied like on the playground like
always trying to be the one that has the
smartest responses like bro that's not
what the conversation is about the
conversation is not about being the
person to deliver the message that
everyone hears about getting the right
message no